TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The advanced Android app
development online course
has been updated,
improved, and extended.
With it, you can build
a portfolio of apps
as you improve your
Android dev skills.
The course is linked from the
post in the description below.
We recently launched
AIY projects,
do-it-yourself artificial
intelligence for makers.
With it, makers can use
artificial intelligence
to make human-to-machine
interaction more
like human-to-human
interactions.
We'll be releasing a
series of reference kits,
starting with voice recognition.
More details and
links are on the post.
Chrome 59 beta is now available
with headless chromium,
native notifications on Mac
OS, service worker navigation
pre-load, and more.
All the details are on the post.
Google Cloud Launcher has more
Google-maintained containers,
including Cassandra,
ElasticSearch, Jenkins,
MySQL, and more.
Google Container solutions are
managed by Google engineers,
and since we're
maintaining the images,
the containers available
on Google Cloud Launcher
will be current with the
latest application and security
updates.
There are two announcements from
Google Cloud Next London that I
wanted to tell you about.
First, Google Cloud
Natural language API
is adding support for new
languages and entity sentiment
analysis.
And second, Cloud Spanner
is now generally available.
Check out the details of both
announcements on the post.
Google I/O is just around the
corner, and if you're like me,
you like to go in
prepared, which
is why we have an Android
iOS and web app to help you
customize your I/O schedule
and get around the developer
festival.
Check out the screenshots,
and find the download links
on the post in the
description below.
Please subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
Google I/O is next week,
so it's time to study.
If you missed any of our
shows, we're here for you.
There's some links
right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]